Come on over. You'll love our backyard. The kids will have a blast. Let us give you the tour. We've got plenty of space for everyone. And later, we'll get together. There's always an extra seat at our table. New Brunswick, always inviting. Visit tourismnewbrunswick.ca Music Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website.
过来吧。你会喜欢我们的后院的。孩子们会玩得很开心的。让我们带你参观一下。我们有足够的空间容纳每个人。稍后，我们会聚在一起。我们的餐桌上总会多出一个座位。新不伦瑞克，永远热情好客。请访问 tourismnewbrunswick.ca 音乐 本期节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上本期节目的节目说明。
Music In December 1924, amid the growing post-war recession and the aftermath of a crippling hyperinflation, Germany was transfixed by a monster. Described as debonair and over-polite, 45-year-old Fritz Harman freely confessed to the sexual assault and murder of numerous boys and young men. While some details of his crimes were deemed too gruesome for publication, there were still plenty of grim fodder for the media to report on. They dubbed Harman the Vampire of Hanover and the Wolfman after he claimed to have killed his victims by biting through their necks for his own sexual gratification. Then, using his skills as a professional butcher, Harman dismembered his victims and disposed of their remains in a nearby river. This earned him the additional title of The Butcher of Hanover. It was also rumoured that he'd consumed his victims' flesh, though evidence and experts soundly disputed this claim.
音乐 1924年12月，在战后日益严重的经济衰退和毁灭性恶性通货膨胀的余波中，德国被一个怪物所震慑。45岁的弗里茨·哈尔曼（Fritz Harman）被描述为风度翩翩、过分客气，他坦白了对多名男孩和年轻男子的性侵犯和谋杀。虽然他的一些犯罪细节被认为过于残忍而不宜公开，但媒体仍有大量令人毛骨悚然的素材可以报道。他们称哈尔曼为“汉诺威吸血鬼”和“狼人”，因为他声称自己为了满足性快感，通过咬断受害者的脖子来杀害他们。然后，利用他作为专业屠夫的技能，哈尔曼将受害者肢解，并将遗骸丢弃在附近的河流中。这为他赢得了“汉诺威屠夫”的额外称号。还有传言称他食用了受害者的肉，尽管证据和专家都坚决反驳了这一说法。
On December 191924, Fritz Harman was convicted on 24 counts of murder and sentenced to death. In a dramatic display that typified the man he was, Harman declared that he would, quote, go to the decapitating block joyfully and happily. Following news of Harman's fate, the German people breathed a collective sigh of relief. The monster had been defeated, or so they thought. The morning after the Vampire of Hanover was condemned, a second monster emerged 600 kilometres away in the town of Munsterberg. Music 41-year-old Vincent Solivier was a stoneworker by trade. As a younger man in the pre-war years, he might have been a traditional journeyman, travelling throughout the region and honing his craft in exchange for meals and board.
1924年12月19日，弗里茨·哈尔曼被判24项谋杀罪名成立，并被判处死刑。在一次典型的个人表演中，哈尔曼宣称他将“愉快而高兴地走向断头台”。在得知哈尔曼的命运后，德国人民集体松了一口气。怪物被击败了，或者他们是这么认为的。在“汉诺威吸血鬼”被定罪后的第二天早上，600公里外的明斯特贝格镇出现了第二个怪物。音乐 41岁的文森特·索利维尔（Vincent Solivier）是一名石匠。作为战前年代的年轻人，他可能是一名传统的流动工匠，在整个地区旅行，以换取食宿来磨练自己的手艺。
But by December 1924, the economic hardship that had swept Germany had reduced Vincent's to a wandering beggar. On Sunday, December 21, Vincent's woke from his first night's sleep in the Munsterberg Evangelical Homeless Shelter. Now known as Jaubitzer in Poland, Munsterberg was a town of about 9,000 people located in what was then the lower Schlesian region of Weimar, Germany. At its heart were the town hall and a small town square, enclosed by densely packed tenement housing that extended a few hundred metres on all sides. Old fortification walls from the Middle Ages partially framed the township, overlooking the farmland and forests beyond. Vincent Solivier set off late in the morning with the intention to beg on the outskirts of Munsterberg, making his way out the northern edge of town he soon found himself walking along Teiststraza. The semi-rural residential street consisted of two-storey, grey brick apartment buildings, each standing a respectable distance from its neighbour.
但到了1924年12月，席卷德国的经济困难使文森特沦为一名流浪乞丐。12月21日星期日，文森特在明斯特贝格福音派收容所度过了他第一晚的睡眠后醒来。明斯特贝格（现波兰境内的Jaubitzer）是一个拥有约9000人口的城镇，位于当时德国魏玛共和国的下西里西亚地区。它的中心是市政厅和一个小广场，被密集排列的公寓楼所包围，这些公寓楼向四周延伸了几百米。中世纪的旧防御墙部分环绕着城镇，俯瞰着远处的农田和森林。文森特·索利维尔在深夜出发，打算在明斯特贝格郊区乞讨，他沿着城镇北缘走去，很快发现自己走在泰斯特拉扎（Teiststraza）街上。这条半乡村的住宅街道由两层楼的灰色砖砌公寓楼组成，每栋楼与邻居保持着相当的距离。
Vincent's approached building number 10. Winter had stripped the trees in the garden bare and a thin layer of snow covered the courtyard. He knocked on the first door and was greeted by Mrs. Voight, a woman in her 40s who lived with her husband and two adult sons. Touched by Vincent's plight, Mrs. Voight handed him 20 fennigs, enough to buy six eggs or nearly a kilo of potatoes. Inspired by this windfall, Vincent's decided to try his luck with the other residents of number 10. Vincent's headed to a flat at the rear of the property and was no doubt pleased when its sole male occupant answered the door as he was known for his generosity towards travellers and beggars. The old man, aged in his 60s, invited Vincent's into his tiny one-room home, offering to match Mrs. Voight's 20 fennigs in exchange for a small favour. Short of sight and unable to write a letter to his brother, he requested that Vincent's sit at the table and transcribe what he dictated.
文森特走近10号楼。冬天剥去了花园里的树叶，一层薄薄的雪覆盖着庭院。他敲了敲第一扇门，迎接他的是沃伊特夫人（Mrs. Voight），一位40多岁的女性，与丈夫和两个成年儿子住在一起。被文森特的困境所打动，沃伊特夫人给了他20芬尼，足够买六个鸡蛋或近一公斤土豆。受到这笔意外之财的鼓舞，文森特决定在10号楼的其他住户身上碰碰运气。文森特前往该房产后部的一间公寓，当唯一的男性住户开门时，他无疑感到很高兴，因为此人以对旅行者和乞丐的慷慨而闻名。这位60多岁的老人邀请文森特进入他狭小的一居室家中，提出以20芬尼作为回报，请他帮一个小忙。由于视力不佳且无法给兄弟写信，他请求文森特坐在桌边，记录下他口述的内容。
Happy to oblige, Vincent's entered the flat and closed the door behind him. Minutes later, Mrs. Voight heard a loud crash followed by shouting. The commotion had arisen from the rear of number 10, where Father Denka lived. She sent her two sons to investigate and upon arriving at Father Denka's flat, they found his front door open and chaos unfolding inside. Father Denka was locked in a fierce struggle with Vincent's Olivier as the men grappled for control of a pickaxe. The Voight brothers dove into the fray and pulled the pair apart. The brothers then called for their father, who took possession of the pickaxe. As Vincent's was ushered out into the hallway, he told the Voight's through gulping breaths that the old man had tried to kill him.
文森特欣然同意，进入公寓并关上了身后的门。几分钟后，沃伊特夫人听到一声巨响，随后是叫喊声。骚乱来自10号楼的后部，丹卡神父（Father Denka）住在那儿。她派两个儿子去调查，当他们到达丹卡神父的公寓时，发现前门开着，里面一片混乱。丹卡神父正与文森特·索利维尔激烈搏斗，两人争夺一把鹤嘴锄。沃伊特兄弟冲入战局，将两人拉开。兄弟俩随后呼唤他们的父亲，父亲夺过了鹤嘴锄。当文森特被带到走廊时，他喘着粗气告诉沃伊特一家，那个老人试图杀他。
For those who knew Father Denka, the possibility that he would try to kill someone was absurd. But blood was flowing from Vincent's head, so it was clear that something had happened. Vincent's didn't want to get police involved, aware he'd be reprimanded for begging in the first place. He just wanted to retrieve his hat from Denka's and be on his way. The Voight's escorted him back in, finding Father Denka standing in the middle of the room flushed red and visibly trembling. His eyes fixated on Vincent's as the younger man retrieved his hat off the sideboard. Through clenched teeth, Denka told the Voight's that the beggar had tried to rob him. Despite Vincent's objections, the Voight's believed this was a matter for the police and escorted him to the local station.
对于那些认识丹卡神父的人来说，他试图杀人的可能性是荒谬的。但文森特的头上流着血，所以很明显发生了什么事。文森特不想让警察介入，因为他知道自己会因乞讨而受到训斥。他只想从丹卡那里拿回他的帽子，然后继续赶路。沃伊特一家护送他回去，发现丹卡神父站在房间中央，满脸通红，浑身颤抖。当那个年轻人从餐具柜上拿回帽子时，他的眼睛死死盯着文森特。丹卡咬牙切齿地告诉沃伊特一家，这个乞丐试图抢劫他。尽管文森特表示反对，但沃伊特一家认为这是警察的事，并将他护送到当地派出所。
Vincent's maintained that he didn't do anything to provoke the man they called Father Denka, but officers were unconvinced. Father Denka was a well-known and respected member of the community who'd lived in Munsterburg for over 30 years without incident. They arrested Vincent's Olivier on suspicion of begging and vagrancy and placed him in a cell. They were not completely unsympathetic to Vincent's condition, however. A doctor was summoned to treat his head wound, which turned out to be a long, wide gash to the right side of his temple. The seriousness of this wound, coupled with Vincent's insistence that he was the victim, prompted police to bring Father Denka in for questioning. Denka told officers that he had paid Vincent's 20 fenigs to pen a letter on his behalf. Vincent's then tried to rob him of the remainder of his coins, inciting the altercation.
文森特坚持说他没有做任何事来激怒那个被称为丹卡神父的人，但警察并不相信。丹卡神父是社区中一位知名且受人尊敬的成员，在明斯特贝格生活了30多年，从未发生过任何事故。他们以涉嫌乞讨和流浪为由逮捕了文森特·索利维尔，并将他关进牢房。然而，他们并非完全不同情文森特的状况。一名医生被传唤来处理他的头部伤口，结果发现右侧太阳穴有一道又长又宽的伤口。伤口的严重性，加上文森特坚持自己是受害者，促使警方带丹卡神父进行审讯。丹卡告诉警官，他付给文森特20芬尼请他代写一封信。文森特随后试图抢劫他剩下的硬币，从而引发了冲突。
The police were willing to believe Father Denka's version of events, however, just to be sure, they decided to keep him in a holding cell at the station while they investigated further. Townsfolk were appalled to learn that the admired Father Denka was in police custody based on the accusations of an itinerant beggar. As a younger man before the war, Father Denka had been a dedicated Lutheran who performed the esteemed role of processional cross-bearer during funerals at the local evangelical church. He was not an ordained minister or a pastor. Rather, the term father was affectionately given to him by the people of Munsterburg in response to his gentle nature and unconditional generosity. Despite only scraping by himself, Father Denka welcomed the vulnerable and destitute into his home, offering them a few coins in exchange for odd jobs. Before they departed, he'd gift them with a handmade craft. Father Denka's first name was Karl. Karl Denka moved to Munsterburg in his late 20s, where he bought a small farm using the inheritance he'd received following his father's death. Denka's lack of financial know-how resulted in him paying about three times what the farm was worth.
警方愿意相信丹卡神父的说法，但为了保险起见，他们决定在调查期间将他关在派出所的拘留室里。镇民们得知受人敬仰的丹卡神父因一个流浪乞丐的指控而被警方拘留，感到非常震惊。战前作为年轻人时，丹卡神父是一位虔诚的路德宗信徒，在当地福音派教堂的葬礼上担任受人尊敬的游行十字架手。他不是受过按立的牧师或神职人员。相反，“神父”这个称呼是明斯特贝格人民因他温和的性格和无条件的慷慨而亲切地给予他的。尽管自己也勉强维持生计，丹卡神父还是欢迎弱势和贫困者进入他的家中，给他们几枚硬币以换取零工。在他们离开之前，他会送给他们一件手工制作的工艺品。丹卡神父的名字叫卡尔（Karl）。卡尔·丹卡在20多岁时搬到明斯特贝格，用他父亲去世后继承的遗产买了一个小农场。丹卡缺乏财务知识，导致他支付的价格大约是农场价值的三倍。
Though Denka wasn't particularly close to his family, his siblings worried that his inadequate farming skills and limited intelligence would cause him to run the property into the ground. Claiming they were looking out for his best interests, they applied to have him deemed legally incapable in an effort to rescind the farm purchase or establish some form of guardianship. The application was ultimately dropped and Denka, betrayed by his siblings' actions, withdrew even further away from his family and public life in general. The concerns held by his family proved true when Denka was eventually forced to sell his farm. He bought the tenement property at number 10 Taistraza with the proceeds, residing in the rear flat while renting out the remaining rooms. When the post-war hyperinflation set in, Denka desperately needed more cash. He sold number 10 but was able to remain in his room as a tenant. He made a living making armchairs and woven bread baskets and selling salted pork and bones at the local meat market.
虽然丹卡与家人的关系并不特别亲密，但他的兄弟姐妹担心他不足的耕作技能和有限的智力会导致他把房产搞垮。声称他们是为了他的最大利益着想，他们申请将他定为法律上的无行为能力人，试图撤销农场购买或建立某种形式的监护权。该申请最终被撤回，丹卡因兄弟姐妹的行为感到背叛，进一步退出了家庭和公共生活。当丹卡最终被迫卖掉他的农场时，他家人的担忧被证明是正确的。他用所得款项购买了泰斯特拉扎10号的公寓房产，住在后部的公寓里，并将剩余的房间出租。当战后恶性通货膨胀来袭时，丹卡迫切需要更多的现金。他卖掉了10号楼，但能够作为租户留在自己的房间里。他靠制作扶手椅和编织面包篮，以及在当地肉类市场出售腌猪肉和骨头为生。
When meat became scarce during the war and the years that followed, Denka resorted to the illegal slaughter of dogs to maintain his stock. Given his good reputation and the desperate times, the authorities were prepared to look the other way. True to his kind-hearted nature, Father Denka initially offered his garden as a playground for local sick children, but eventually reclaimed the space to make additional income. During on the skills he'd learned as an apprentice gardener in his teens, he began cultivating and selling rhubarb. As a result, Denka was regarded as the rhubarb king. Although well regarded as a generous man, a father, and a king, Denka was not without flaws. Despite the country's economic woes, Karl Denka was strong and well fed, exposing his gluttonous love for food. He was known to consume two pounds of meat in a single meal.
当战争期间及随后的几年里肉类变得稀缺时，丹卡诉诸非法屠宰狗来维持库存。鉴于他的良好声誉和绝望的时代，当局准备睁一只眼闭一只眼。出于他善良的本性，丹卡神父最初提供他的花园作为当地生病儿童的游乐场，但最终收回了空间以增加收入。利用他在十几岁时作为园丁学徒学到的技能，他开始种植和销售大黄。因此，丹卡被视为“大黄之王”。虽然被视为一个慷慨的人、一位神父和一位国王，但丹卡并非没有缺点。尽管国家经济困难，卡尔·丹卡却身体强壮、营养充足，暴露了他对食物的贪婪热爱。众所周知，他一顿饭能吃掉两磅肉。
He also harboured chauvinistic attitudes towards women. An eccentric loner, Father Denka had nevertheless indeared himself to the people of Munsterburg. His fight with Vincent Solovier was an uncharacteristic blight on his otherwise impeccable reputation. Father Denka was set to spend the night in a cell as police determined what exactly took place between him and Vincent Solovier. At 9.30 that evening, a sergeant went to check on the old man and was confronted by a shocking sight. Father Denka was suspended about half a metre off the floor by a handkerchief tied around his neck. The abrupt suicide of Father Denka was equal parts confounding and unexpected. Whether out of staunch adherence to the letter of the law or in retaliation for the death of Father Denka,
他还对女性持有沙文主义态度。作为一个古怪的独行侠，丹卡神父却赢得了明斯特贝格人民的喜爱。他与文森特·索利维尔的打斗是他原本无可挑剔的声誉上一个不寻常的污点。丹卡神父将在牢房里过夜，警方正在确定他和文森特·索利维尔之间到底发生了什么。那天晚上9点30分，一名警官去查看这位老人，被眼前的一幕惊呆了。丹卡神父被一根系在脖子上的手帕悬挂在离地约半米的地方。丹卡神父的突然自杀既令人困惑又出人意料。无论是出于对法律条文的坚定遵守，还是为了报复丹卡神父的死亡，
Vincent Solovier was charged with begging and vagrancy and remanded for trial in three weeks time. Father Denka's estranged family were notified of his death, but they refused to collect his body or pay for his funeral. So it was left to the local authorities to arrange his burial. Two days later on Christmas Eve, the police attended Father Denka's apartment to take inventory of any cash or valuable items that could be sold to cover the cost of his burial. Upon entering, they were struck by how filthy the cramped space was. A foul stench hung in the air and every surface, including the floor, was covered in jars, pots, bowls, half woven baskets and bundles of rags. Among the clutter were piles of papers that detailed Denka's rhubarb sales. As officers flipped through the pages, they uncovered something strange.
文森特·索利维尔被控乞讨和流浪罪，并被还押候审，三周后受审。丹卡神父疏远的家人被通知了他的死讯，但他们拒绝收尸或支付葬礼费用。因此，只能由当地政府安排他的安葬。两天后的平安夜，警察来到丹卡神父的公寓，清点可以出售以支付葬礼费用的现金或贵重物品。进入后，他们被狭窄空间里的肮脏程度所震惊。空气中弥漫着恶臭，每一个表面，包括地板，都覆盖着罐子、锅、碗、半编织的篮子和成捆的破布。杂物中还有一堆堆详细记录丹卡大黄销售情况的文件。当警官翻阅这些页面时，他们发现了一些奇怪的东西。
Tucked between them were personal documents pertaining to other men. There was a prison release card in the name of Herman Moeller and a hospital discharge form for a man named Johann Tomola. Failing to find anything of significant monetary value from their cursory search of the flat, officers headed out to the backyard and into a small wooden shed. Inside, Father Denka had built a mezzanine level with some scaffolding to increase storage capacity. From below, the officers could see at least one wooden barrel sitting up there. Clothes and other bundles of laundry took up the majority of the remaining space. There was also a large wooden bucket about 40cm in diameter on the ground. It contained various cuts of cured meat settled in a salt solution.
夹在中间的是涉及其他男性的个人文件。有一张以赫尔曼·穆勒（Herman Moeller）名义签发的监狱释放卡，以及一张名为约翰·托莫拉（Johann Tomola）的男子的医院出院表。在对公寓的粗略搜查中未能找到任何具有重大货币价值的东西，警官们前往后院，进入了一个小木棚。在里面，丹卡神父用一些脚手架搭建了一个夹层，以增加存储容量。从下面，警官们可以看到上面至少放着一个木桶。衣服和其他成捆的衣物占据了剩余空间的大部分。地上还有一个直径约40厘米的大木桶。里面装有各种腌制肉块，浸泡在盐溶液中。
This wasn't an unusual finding given Father Denka's livelihood. Yet, there was something about the meat that didn't look right. Aware that Father Denka had previously slaughtered dogs for food, attending officers took a closer look into the bucket. One of the pieces of meat caught their attention. The realisation dawned. It wasn't fur sprouting from the pale meaty substance. It was human chest hair. The wooden bucket contained a total of 15 pieces of human flesh, including two portions from a man's torso and a large piece from a buttock.
鉴于丹卡神父的生计，这并不是一个不寻常的发现。然而，肉类有些看起来不对劲。意识到丹卡神父以前曾屠宰狗作为食物，在场的警官仔细查看了桶里。其中一块肉引起了他们的注意。真相大白了。那不是从苍白的肉质物质中长出来的毛发。那是人类的胸毛。木桶里总共装有15块人肉，包括来自一名男子躯干的两部分和一大块臀部肉。
A medical examiner determined that the salted meat mass had come from three different men and had been pickled less than a month prior. As police catalogued the array of clothing found in the wooden shed, it became clear that the items were unlikely to have belonged to Denka. There were coats, trousers, shirts, vests and hats of various sizes, most of which had been washed clean. Those that hadn't were stained with blood. Within the large wooden barrel that sat atop the mezzanine level were hundreds of cleaned and cooked human bones. More were found in a small pond behind the shed and in the surrounding woodlands. In total, 480 individual bones were discovered, indicating that at least eight people had been butchered at the hands of Karl Denka. The gruesome discoveries continued in Denka's flat.
法医确定，这些腌制的肉块来自三名不同的男子，并且在不到一个月前被腌制。当警察对在木棚中发现的各种衣物进行分类时，很明显这些物品不太可能是丹卡的。有各种尺寸的外套、裤子、衬衫、背心和帽子，其中大部分已被洗净。那些没洗的则沾满了血迹。在位于夹层顶部的木桶里，有数百块清洗过并煮熟的人骨。在棚子后面的一个小池塘和周围的林地里发现了更多。总共发现了480块独立的骨头，表明至少有八人死于卡尔·丹卡之手。令人毛骨悚然的发现还在丹卡的公寓里继续。
Two tin boxes, one labelled pepper and the other salt, didn't contain condiments. They actually held dozens of pulled human teeth. More were found in a wallet and several paper bags, bringing the total amount of individual teeth found to 351. The director of the local dental institute conservatively predicted that they belonged to at least 25 individuals. Traces of human blood were found on a wood saw and a tree saw. Blood was also identified on the pickaxe that Denka had wielded when he fought Vincent's Olivier. A gelatinous yellow mass in a bowl on a table was confirmed to be human fat. Three enamel pots on the iron stovetop contained portions of cooked human flesh covered in a creamy sauce.
两个锡盒，一个贴着“胡椒”标签，另一个贴着“盐”，里面装的不是调味品。它们实际上装有几十颗拔下来的人类牙齿。在钱包和几个纸袋里发现了更多，使发现的牙齿总数达到351颗。当地牙科研究所所长保守估计，它们至少属于25个人。在木锯和树锯上发现了人类血迹。在丹卡与文森特·索利维尔打斗时使用的鹤嘴锄上也鉴定出了血迹。桌上碗里的一团胶状黄色物质被证实是人体脂肪。铁炉灶上的三个搪瓷锅里装有覆盖着奶油酱的煮熟人肉。
Some with hair still protruding from the skin. One of the pots was half empty. The horrific discovery of Karl Denka's crimes offered an explanation as to why the old man had abruptly and inexplicably taken his own life after coming to the attention of police. Karl Denka's neighbours recalled his midnight strolls into the nearby woods and observed him carrying in large parcels but returning empty handed. They considered it odd but didn't think it was up to anything sinister. On many occasions they had witnessed him hauling pots of meat from his flat to the wooden shed and pouring the bloody contents of his buckets into the courtyard drainage. At the time, their only real curiosity was where he got his dog meat in such high volumes. They occasionally noticed a foul smell coming from Denka's apartment but it always disappeared once they raised the issue with him.
有些皮肤上还长着毛发。其中一个锅是半空的。卡尔·丹卡罪行的可怕发现解释了为什么这位老人在引起警方注意后，突然且莫名其妙地结束了自己的生命。卡尔·丹卡的邻居们回忆起他午夜在附近树林里的漫步，并观察到他带着大包裹进去，但回来时却空手而归。他们认为这很奇怪，但没觉得他在做什么邪恶的事情。在许多场合，他们曾目睹他将肉锅从公寓搬到木棚，并将桶里血淋淋的内容物倒入庭院排水沟。当时，他们唯一真正的好奇是他从哪里弄来如此大量的狗肉。他们偶尔会注意到丹卡的公寓里传出一股恶臭，但每当他们向他提出这个问题时，它总是会消失。
They assumed that the chopping and soaring sounds emanating from his place at all hours of the night was just Denka constructing his armchairs. As news of Denka's disturbing appetite spread, more people looked back at their own experiences with the introverted builder butcher with heightened suspicion. A woman insisted she had once seen a human navel on Denka's dining table. One winter, children had found a thumb frozen in the pond. It also emerged that two other beggars had managed to escape Denka's attacks a year or so earlier. One had broken free from a chain wrapped around his neck. The other ran out of Denka's apartment covered in blood. Knowing they would likely be charged with begging and vagrancy, neither reported the assault to the police.
他们以为他住处在深夜里传出的砍伐和锯木声只是丹卡在制作扶手椅。随着丹卡令人不安的胃口的消息传开，更多的人带着高度的怀疑回顾了他们自己与这位内向的建筑工兼屠夫的经历。一位妇女坚持说她曾经在丹卡的餐桌上看到过一个人类肚脐。一个冬天，孩子们在池塘里发现了一根冻住的大拇指。还有消息称，另外两名乞丐在一年前左右成功逃脱了丹卡的袭击。一个从缠在脖子上的链条中挣脱出来。另一个满身是血地跑出了丹卡的公寓。因为知道他们很可能会被控乞讨和流浪罪，两人都没有向警方报告袭击事件。
Denka's family offered insight into what cultivated his disturbed mindset. They described him as a lazy and petulant child who long suffered with a bedwetting problem. He started his first words when he was about six years old, with many viewing his silence as a lack of intelligence. As he grew, so did his indifference toward his family and people in general. He was said to have had no fear, harboured no disgust, and appeared emotionally numb. This family described his fascination with the Daniel Defoe's 18th century novel, Robinson Crusoe. Particularly the passages describing and illustrations depicting cannibals eating their victims. Karl Denka's crimes made headlines across Germany and the world.
丹卡的家人提供了关于是什么培养了他扭曲心态的见解。他们形容他是一个懒惰且任性的孩子，长期患有尿床问题。他大约六岁时才开始说第一句话，许多人认为他的沉默是缺乏智力的表现。随着他的成长，他对家人和一般人的冷漠也随之增长。据说他没有恐惧，没有厌恶，并且在情感上显得麻木。这个家庭描述了他对丹尼尔·笛福18世纪小说《鲁滨逊漂流记》的迷恋。特别是描述和描绘食人族吃掉受害者的段落和插图。卡尔·丹卡的罪行登上了德国乃至全世界的头条新闻。
Many likened his actions to the vampire of Hanover, Fritz Harman. However, where Harman did not eat the flesh of his victims, Denka most assuredly did. A meticulous record keeper, Denka had documented his victims' details on pages found within the piles of paperwork in his flat. His first victim was listed simply as Eda, with February 21, 1903 as her date of death. Investigators would later determine that this woman was Eda Launa, who disappeared that day while en route to visit a friend. In total, Denka had filled four pages with victims' details. The final entry on the list did not include a name, only a date of death, November 17, 1924, a month prior to his suicide. According to Denka's list, this person was victim number 31. Karl Denka had been killing for 21 years.
许多人将他的行为与“汉诺威吸血鬼”弗里茨·哈尔曼相提并论。然而，哈尔曼并没有吃掉受害者的肉，而丹卡肯定吃了。作为一个一丝不苟的记录员，丹卡在他公寓里的一堆文书工作中记录了他受害者的详细信息。他的第一个受害者名单上只列为“埃达”（Eda），死亡日期为1903年2月21日。调查人员后来确定，这名女子是埃达·劳娜（Eda Launa），她在那天去探望朋友的途中失踪了。总共，丹卡填满了四页受害者详细信息。名单上的最后一个条目没有名字，只有一个死亡日期，1924年11月17日，在他自杀前一个月。根据丹卡的名单，这个人是第31号受害者。卡尔·丹卡已经杀人21年了。
The majority of Denka's victims were travelling craftsmen, carpenters, locksmiths, blacksmiths, mechanics and gardeners. No doubt intentionally selected as they wouldn't be noticed as missing. They were mostly males in their late 50s to early 60s, however four women did appear on the list. Denka's youngest victim was a 15-year-old boy named Avald Koernig, who was murdered during the war on August 15, 1915. His oldest victim was a 75-year-old baker named Julius Busch, whose life was taken on March 13, 1921. There was also a separate list of shorthand names that corresponded with the victim list. Next to each name was a number that represented their slaughter weight. That was the net weight of their body after their blood, organs, head and genitals had been removed.
丹卡的大多数受害者是流动的工匠、木匠、锁匠、铁匠、机械师和园丁。毫无疑问，他们是故意挑选的，因为他们失踪了也不会被注意到。他们大多是50多岁到60岁出头的男性，但名单上也出现了四名女性。丹卡最年轻的受害者是一个名叫阿瓦尔德·科尼格（Avald Koernig）的15岁男孩，他在战争期间的1915年8月15日被谋杀。他最年长的受害者是一位名叫朱利叶斯·布施（Julius Busch）的75岁面包师，他的生命在1921年3月13日被夺走。还有一份单独的速记名字列表，与受害者名单相对应。每个名字旁边都有一个数字，代表他们的屠宰重量。那是他们的身体在血液、器官、头部和生殖器被移除后的净重。
Investigators concluded that Denka had prepared just over £2,500 of human flesh for consumption. The sheer amount raised genuine fears that he had sold some of the meat as skinless-corned pork to marketplaces in the region's capital. This prospect horrified one newlywed couple as all the meat served at their wedding feast months prior had been purchased from Karl Denka. Yet there was no evidence to indicate that Denka sold human flesh to others. He did serve meat to visitors at his flat, though its origin could no longer be ascertained. Nevertheless, meat consumption in Munsterberg dropped significantly in the weeks following Karl Denka's death. The revelation that Denka was a prolific cannibal serial killer was horrifying enough. However, the discovery of other seemingly innocuous items would only heighten his depravity.
调查人员得出结论，丹卡准备了超过2500英镑的人肉供食用。巨大的数量引起了真正的担忧，即他可能将部分肉作为去皮腌猪肉卖给了该地区首府的市场。这一前景让一对新婚夫妇感到恐惧，因为他们几个月前婚礼宴席上供应的所有肉类都是从卡尔·丹卡那里购买的。然而，没有证据表明丹卡将人肉卖给他人。他确实在公寓里为访客提供肉食，尽管其来源已无法确定。尽管如此，在卡尔·丹卡死后的几周里，明斯特贝格的肉类消费量显著下降。丹卡是一名多产的食人连环杀手的揭露已经足够令人恐惧。然而，其他看似无害物品的发现只会加剧他的堕落。
In addition to those in Denka's wooden shed, more bundles of clothing and material had been found in his flat. All had been neatly tied with narrow straps of human skin. Closer inspection of the bread baskets revealed that they too were woven from the skin of Denka's victims. The police also discovered three pairs of yellowish-brown suspenders, each about 6 cm wide and 70 cm long. All had been made from strips of dried human skin. At least one pair had been cut vertically from a man's torso, as two nipples were clearly visible. Another had been repaired with patches of skin from a man's pubic region. No one noticed at the time, but Denka had been wearing this pair when he died in his cell.
除了丹卡木棚里的那些，在他的公寓里还发现了更多成捆的衣服和材料。所有这些都用窄窄的人皮带整齐地捆绑着。仔细检查面包篮发现，它们也是用丹卡受害者的皮肤编织而成的。警方还发现了三副黄褐色的吊带，每副宽约6厘米，长70厘米。全部都是用干人皮条制成的。至少有一副是从一名男子的躯干上垂直切割下来的，因为两个乳头清晰可见。另一副是用一名男子阴部的皮肤补丁修复的。当时没有人注意到，但丹卡在牢房里去世时戴着这副吊带。
It was now abundantly clear that Vincent's Olivier had been telling the truth all along. He had not attempted to rob Father Denka as the old man had alleged. After entering Denka's apartment, Vincent had placed his hat on the small console and sat down at the table, while Denka hovered behind him a little to the right. Denka wanted Vincent to address the letter to his brother, followed by the words, you fat paunch. Amused by the phrase, Vincent laughed and turned his head to share the joke with Denka, just in time to see a pickaxe swinging down towards him. Unable to dodge the blow completely, Vincent was struck on the right side of his skull. He regained his awareness just as Denka raised the pickaxe for a second time. Vincent quickly wrapped his hands around the pickaxe's handle and the two men wrestled for control.
现在非常清楚，文森特·索利维尔一直都在说实话。他并没有像那个老人所指控的那样试图抢劫丹卡神父。进入丹卡的公寓后，文森特把帽子放在小控制台上，坐在桌边，而丹卡则在他身后稍微偏右的地方徘徊。丹卡想让文森特给他的兄弟写信，后面跟着“你这个大肚腩”这几个字。文森特被这个短语逗乐了，笑了笑，转过头去和丹卡分享这个笑话，正好看到一把鹤嘴锄向他挥来。由于无法完全躲过这一击，文森特的头骨右侧被击中。就在丹卡第二次举起鹤嘴锄时，他恢复了意识。文森特迅速用双手抓住鹤嘴锄的柄，两人争夺控制权。
Despite Denka's age and short stature, it was a fairly even physical match. The pair pushed each other around the tiny space, crashing into the table and sending glass jars and crockery pots smashing to the ground. Vincent was able to wrench the pickaxe out of Denka's hands, open the door and scream for help. The old man threw himself upon Vincent's in crazed determination. Finally, the two Voight brothers appeared and the fight was over. Karl Denka had no doubt intended for Vincent's Olivier to be victim number 32. In the early hours of December 31, 1924, Karl Denka's body was buried in an unmarked grave. Twelve days later, many of his personal effects were reduced to ashes in a bonfire.
尽管丹卡的年龄和身材矮小，但这在体力上相当均衡。两人在狭小的空间里互相推搡，撞到桌子上，把玻璃罐和陶罐摔得粉碎。文森特设法从丹卡手中夺过鹤嘴锄，打开门大声呼救。老人疯狂地扑向文森特。最后，沃伊特兄弟出现了，打斗结束了。卡尔·丹卡无疑是想让文森特·索利维尔成为第32号受害者。1924年12月31日凌晨，卡尔·丹卡的尸体被埋葬在一个无名墓中。十二天后，他的许多个人物品在篝火中化为灰烬。
Despite barely escaping with his life, on January 15, 1925, Vincent's Olivier stood trial and was sentenced to a further 10 days in prison for begging and vagrancy. Denka's victim list suggested he had murdered and consumed a total of 31 people, but investigators were certain the true number was much higher. Other pages among Denka's paperwork belonged to wandering craftsmen whose names were not on his list, but whose clothing were in his possession. Despite his initial notoriety, Karl Denka eventually faded from public consciousness. Although he was far more prolific and arguably more disturbed than the vampire of Hanover Fritz Harman, the latter's vocal theatrics ensured Denka was forgotten in his shadows. Thus, Karl Denka became known as the Forgotten Cannibal. 25-year-old Emma Sander lived in the small town of Neuhoof, less than six kilometres north of Munsterburg. On December 21, 1909, Emma vanished while on her way to work.
尽管几乎没能保住性命，但1925年1月15日，文森特·索利维尔仍因乞讨和流浪罪受审，并被判处额外10天监禁。丹卡的受害者名单显示他总共谋杀了并食用了31人，但调查人员确信真实数字要高得多。丹卡文书工作中的其他页面属于流浪工匠，他们的名字不在他的名单上，但他们的衣服却在他手中。尽管最初声名狼藉，卡尔·丹卡最终还是淡出了公众意识。虽然他比“汉诺威吸血鬼”弗里茨·哈尔曼多产得多，也更有可能更令人不安，但后者的口头戏剧性确保了丹卡被遗忘在他的阴影中。因此，卡尔·丹卡被称为“被遗忘的食人者”。25岁的艾玛·桑德（Emma Sander）住在明斯特贝格以北不到六公里的诺伊霍夫（Neuhoof）小镇。1909年12月21日，艾玛在上班途中失踪。
In the coming days, her naked torso, arms and head were found separately in the woods outside of town. Her lower legs were recovered near a railway line. Emma had been choked unconscious, then killed by a method of slaughter popular with butchers for its efficiency and lack of blood splatter known as the mutton sting. Given this procedure and the expertly performed dismemberment of Emma's body, authorities concluded that her killer was a trained butcher. Suspicion quickly fell onto a local butcher named Edouard Troutman. It was well known that Emma Sander had been terrified of Troutman ever since she rejected his marriage proposal. A witness at Troutman's trial testified that Troutman had declared that he would beat Emma to death if he were ever alone with her. He was also seen wearing a leather coat with sheep wool lining that looked remarkably like one that had belonged to Emma.
在接下来的几天里，她赤裸的躯干、手臂和头部在镇外的树林里被分别发现。她的小腿在铁路线附近被找回。艾玛被掐晕，然后用一种因其效率高且无血迹飞溅而受屠夫欢迎的屠宰方法——“羊肉刺”（mutton sting）杀害。鉴于这种程序以及对艾玛尸体专业进行的肢解，当局得出结论，她的杀手是一名训练有素的屠夫。怀疑很快落到了一名名叫爱德华·特劳特曼（Edouard Troutman）的当地屠夫身上。众所周知，艾玛·桑德自从拒绝了特劳特曼的求婚后，就一直对他感到恐惧。特劳特曼审判中的一名证人作证说，特劳特曼曾宣称，如果他单独和艾玛在一起，他会把她打死。他还被看到穿着一件带有羊毛衬里的皮大衣，看起来非常像艾玛曾经拥有的一件。
The day after Emma had disappeared, the distinct smell of burning leather and wool had emanated from Troutman's house. Harboring a reputation for violence, Troutman often spouted threats such as, I'll turn you into sausage and I'll cut your head off. He had even once attempted to murder one of his instructors. One master butcher under whom Troutman spent time as an apprentice testified that he'd seen Troutman carry out at least four mutton stings. Despite Edouard Troutman's claims of innocence, he was convicted of Emma Sander's murder in February 1911 and sentenced to 12 years in prison. Troutman was released in January 1923. 15 years after Emma Sander's murder, Carl Denker's crimes were exposed.
艾玛失踪后的第二天，特劳特曼的房子里散发出明显的烧焦皮革和羊毛的味道。特劳特曼以暴力著称，经常喷出诸如“我会把你变成香肠，我会砍掉你的头”之类的威胁。他甚至曾经试图谋杀他的一名导师。特劳特曼曾作为学徒跟随的一位屠夫大师作证说，他曾看到特劳特曼执行过至少四次“羊肉刺”。尽管爱德华·特劳特曼声称自己无罪，但他还是在1911年2月因谋杀艾玛·桑德而被定罪，并被判处12年监禁。特劳特曼于1923年1月获释。艾玛·桑德被谋杀15年后，卡尔·丹卡的罪行被曝光。
The name Emma was listed in his notes as his second victim. There wasn't a surname, but Denker had included her date of death, which coincided with the date Emma Sander had disappeared. Authorities soon realized that they had made a terrible mistake. Edouard Troutman was telling the truth. He did not kill Emma Sander. Troutman's conviction for the murder of Emma Sander was overturned in March 1926. The jury's guilty verdict had been questionable given the time frame in which Troutman had apparently committed the crime. He visited the Neuhulf Inn at the time Emma was set upon.
“艾玛”的名字被列在他的笔记中，作为他的第二个受害者。没有姓氏，但丹卡包含了她的死亡日期，这与艾玛·桑德失踪的日期相吻合。当局很快意识到他们犯了一个可怕的错误。爱德华·特劳特曼说的是实话。他没有杀害艾玛·桑德。特劳特曼因谋杀艾玛·桑德而被定罪的判决于1926年3月被推翻。考虑到特劳特曼显然犯下罪行的时间框架，陪审团的有罪判决是值得怀疑的。在艾玛遇袭时，他正在访问诺伊霍夫旅馆。
This permitted him a strict five-minute window in which he confronted, strangled, bled out and dismembered the young woman. Even a skilled butcher such as Troutman could not have completed such lengthy procedures in so little time. Emma was the only victim whose slaughter weight was not recorded on Carl Denker's list. As Detective Polka noted, this was because Denker hadn't used any of the meat for himself. A strange injury found on one of Emma Sander's lower legs now made grim sense. A long, wide strip of skin had been removed from her shin. Thank you for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这给了他严格的五分钟时间窗口，在此期间他与这名年轻女子对峙、勒死、放血并肢解。即使是像特劳特曼这样熟练的屠夫，也不可能在这么短的时间内完成如此漫长的程序。艾玛是唯一一个屠宰重量没有记录在卡尔·丹卡名单上的受害者。正如波尔卡（Polka）侦探所指出的，这是因为丹卡没有为自己使用任何肉。在艾玛·桑德的一条小腿上发现的一种奇怪伤口现在有了令人毛骨悚然的解释。她的小腿上被剥去了一长条宽大的皮肤。感谢您的观看。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。